andando mesmo tem quase 10 quilos que
está nossa energia em inglês 2 o gado
não só que curso olha o pessoal aqui
quem fala é o dar que sejam muito bem
vindos à margem bilhão e mostrados aqui
mais um vídeo denar vejam só mesmo que o
ritmo é muito linda ai weiwei é
automática
mas com essa chance o goleiro e ela vai
direitinha chapa na coleção olha aí vai
lá e vamos mostrar agora porém são
muitos nerds que eu tenho aqui muda sei
o que me interessa é muito grande
olha sou tua mãe dela pode o que eu
gosto mais é que o tenho uma pega aqui
pra galera falei isso aí é uma outra
coisa que eu adorei neps que é o fato de
elas terem desmontáveis algumas já está
completamente montavam mas não só aí tem
uma peça aqui ainda tem isto porque pega
e tem por trás e saque o que ainda dá
pra ficar mais pequeno que o sinal ela
contasse ambas têm aqui um vizinho mali
de vôlei fica piscando formando muito
longa mas não só que tem que basicamente
a primeira opção fácil assim barsotti
não dar essa opção eu tive três babá pa
e última opção tinha todos os dados que
vai pensar como a melhor forma de ter
uma noção melhor do que esta porque ela
é automática já têm tudo até onde os
olhos todos só vou juntar todas as
mulheres que eu tenho na cana ainda vou
juntar esta basta imaginar em tudo junto
numa nota fala aí é muita 0 e precisa
passar ainda falta precisa da nossa
ajuda porque por ele só porque eu quero
muito a equipe neste vídeo vocês acharem
muito aqui neste vídeo eu vou lançar
três deles se mais vídeos com brinquedos
tipo nerds e coisas assim então deixou
muito moleque mesmo e comentei isso
querem ver assim mais vídeos com
brinquedos e só não só isso por escrito
que no canal inscrevemos com toda a
força e as 20 mil cinemas só para não
perderem nenhum vídeo que no canal e
para lá então construir aqui nossa nã há
mas não posso e não posso é preciso
ajuda a primeira fase é porque os
cientistas não é conquista sozinha
porque eu vou chamar uma equipe ao
mandar filmar por agora só tenho que
nosso primeiro módulo do extra montada e
agora é só pegar aqui todas as nossas
não quis montar aqui nesta era meu pai
ficar maneiro diga muito grande
com essas novas todas nessa sim o que
complicou ainda mais para lá e montar
agora os ânimos e sim e alguma coisa
muito grande né eu acho que vou fazer
isso é a nossa nem fui regular
terminasse no primeiro vai ser a base de
tudo isso eu vou aprender agora estas
duas é que do lado vai ficar uma coisa
mais ou menos assim ele vai ficar muito
longe e não só quer ver uma competição
nos comentários
vocês acham que eu vou conseguir
construir essa neve comentei arroz vocês
acham que eu não vou conseguir montar
esta não se cometem influenciam e vamos
ver quem é que ganha o arroz ou feijão
também que os dois juntos são bons nem
por isso foi muito bom
bora lá o cae está a resultar qualquer
só vez não só nosso primeiro nessa
montagem uma na outra olha isso aí
wilson ainda muito me imaginei que fosse
funcionário você vai lá e vamos lá pra
terceira hora que possamos assim né
só vou só conectar muito pesado esta
manhã foi ainda muito grande
eu acho que ele tem construído mas sim
muito grande é só a idéia é só uma idéia
também é mas ela ainda pode ficar muito
maior para lá agora popular quais apenas
duas pequenas peças dos que são iguais é
é porque só vou falar agora estas duas
noites assistindo a eles até podem ficar
na rua clay duas já estão muito cansados
e produtos nas ruas da lapa é cara nova
canaã e joga na bola eu vou começar a
roubar umas não pagá-los
não vou negar que estou nessa região não
só comentei arroz pessoal
temos só a comentar em agosto e se eu
ganhar com a rua nova que vai ter que
comer um quilo de agosto
agora vai ficar pelo menos com feijão
ovo não só usamos bem
cada mil mas como uma pessoa comum em
algumas muito mas deu uma explosão por
mim sal não não salvaguarda da aiea
sobre a sua saúde e olha isso natal e
bonita a sociedade não está muito bonita
série que ainda resta agora só parece
não gostar muito da zahar disse josué
entrou pegando mesmo é só meu
agora é composto por mais em cima disso
vai pois não dá pra pegar ele não pega
vai pra frente só para estes novos e que
elas são completamente simétricas então
eu posso usar a máquina mineiro é porque
assim vai ficar simétrica também para o
pessoal aqui é muito popular no último
ano fizemos lá 321 é muito grande
afirmou
o escolhido é um braço muito sério
mesmo com esse meu pai meus irmãos por
mais vai ficar muito louca que se o
ritmo daqui que já não consegui aguentar
a fazer isso logo porque solta pronta
próximo ao 321 vai mas muito muito feliz
e muito orgulhoso muito bonita essa mer
costa ficam ainda carro mais ficava
imaginando o sac móvel agora para lá
espera lá ainda tem outra muito grande
aí maluco é que olha aí olha aqui ele
tava vida na pureza taxa é composto por
este órgão olha aí fica assim com uma
pedra gigante que só a equipa do euro
está a ganhar eu acho que sim porque
como em todos os jogos para ganhar e vou
ter um carro sem saber quem sofre é o
colar já a nossa luz
i onde o curso aí eu acho que do mal
tempo na fila fora pisei só conhece
muito o jeito que está não tem medo mas
teve que ganhar ao se despedir da mãe
dele fazendo assim só está quase pronta
posso votar agora 321 andré mas não só
também dela
só acho que é melhor não se você já viu
sabe também que nunca viu uma melhora
nos preços durante a fase em campo o que
causa a não mais fazer uma coisa de
abril também sobre quando e se o usuário
assim não se ficam ou não assim aqui ô ô
ô ele vai ficar muito bonito é evitar a
morte é assim como também a moda é um
mundo que eu corro risco
não sei muito fita cola já foi isso tá
tudo bem que não sou maluco é que eu
acho que isso ajuda a financiar de mim
ele disse que hoje não que o gaúcho vai
tomar no caso do arroz a coisa vai
a prefeita mas o que posso falar o ney
franco muito mais porque ela já está a
demonstrar toda mas não mas nas crianças
que ana rocha uma hora que maneira e dá
margem a imagem
lá funcionará assim o que já não dá pra
cima mas vai ter um contato do clube
após deixar está aqui assim vai pronto
assim vai ficar maior o meu deus a xuxa
se perguntar da minha vida qual só
equilibrado agora nossa méxico o barriga
afinal eles é como as serpentes como
burcas só para conseguir aguentar essa
não é porque eu já sabia que eu ia fazer
desse limão só agora vai rolar tudo pro
rock como maneja a há muito táxi
mas vai valer taxista um quilo de arroz
ele tem status falar eu nunca tive uma
idéia não vai machucar em um lance
seguinte perdeu a bola
kapman pec agora olha só ataque balanço
vamos lá ver o piso nacional 321 vai
calma tem quase 10 quilos novo ponto
seis das dez quilos e é isso que os
fumantes mas foi lá e encontraram o
sítio não vou colocar os dados
acho que a equipe passou e que olha aí o
cara já tá cheia quando o funcionário
por um alvo ainda que mal eu não posso
colocar o álbum mais poderoso e e até
isso enquanto isso é muito fácil é fazer
uma nova licitação deve colocar aqui em
cima do triângulo o do extremo de hoje
entre r não só tem esse paralelo entende
a broca
vamos lá ver se ela funciona ela faz um
barulho alexandra cadantu 321 bairro é
muito difícil apontar com ela por quem
tem muito dinheiro foi que depois normal
né
mas todas as manobras é só colocar o
josué e olha isso é ruim não me
interessa quem devia lá e depois é só
assinar o que você tá se você está
maluco eca por vai comer o que eu gosto
porque a equipa do arroz vai ganhar
porque eu já construí nossa senhora
sylvia estarão no álbum é porque ela
funciona então duas primeiras tentar cem
vezes o da também não disse quantas
vezes tentaram roubar o homem que
cometeu erros que nós ganhamos e não
vale a pena possa editar em um
comentário quem comentou feijão por meu
boi
só espero que nenhum estado agüenta e
estimo muito aqui neste vídeo e só se
for em novos aqui no canal inscrevam se
admite ninguém fique bem